there are only so many major news
stories each year and we have one of
them today and this is actually i would
argue one of the biggest news stories of
the decade we've been waiting for the
supreme court's decision on abortion
rights two cases that historically
establish the right to an abortion in
most cases in the united states
those are roe v wade and planned
parenthood v casey the supreme court we
knew sometime in the next few weeks
maybe by the end of june would issue a
decision on a mississippi abortion ban
which
would
in practice overturn roe v wade and
planned parenthood vkc depending on what
the court decides and that decision has
been leaked it has not been announced by
the supreme court but it has been leaked
and reputably so
and if nothing changes
the
supreme court will be overturning
abortion rights as a
federal in most cases right sending it
back to the states plunging many states
back into
should we call it medieval times should
we call it the dark ages should we call
it the 1850s the 1950s there are
actually two cases here most people know
about roe v wade but there's two cases
roe v wade as well as the 1992 planned
parenthood decision uh uh supreme court
decision planned parenthood v casey now
politico got a copy of the draft opinion
and this is this is a major scoop it
really is and there are conservatives
mad about the fact that this leaked but
obtaining this is a major scoop and um
the quote from the
majority opinion believed to be ready to
go in a few weeks is from supreme court
justice samuel alito where he writes
quote
row
was egregiously wrong from the start its
reasoning was exceptionally weak and the
decision has had damaging consequences
and far from bringing about a national
settlement of the abortion issue row and
casey have inflamed debate and deepened
division now before we go forward with
the analysis on the assumption that this
decision isn't going to change we should
put on record in case things do change
that sometimes justices will circulate
draft opinions and there's still
revisions and changes and sometimes
horse trading for votes i mean things
happen you would think that that doesn't
happen at the supreme court but it does
and up until days before it's made
official
opinions can change but right now
roe v wade goes bye-bye
planned parenthood vkc goes bye-bye now
on the issue of blame because i've
gotten a ton of messages from people
about who do we blame here do we blame
the people that didn't vote for hillary
and all this different stuff listen we
most it's like what when there's a uh um
i'm not even gonna make any analogies we
mostly blame the supreme court justices
who voted this way okay that but we
primarily blame them and
when it comes to the supreme court then
you go well why are they there and so
you go to trump we
trump's choices are what made this
a plausible reality and we predicted and
we were worried that it would happen and
it looks like it's happening so we blame
the justices and we blame the president
who put them there who's donald trump
well why was trump there we mostly blame
the people who voted for donald trump
and put him in this position
but we also say hey as an instructive
element
as something we should remember
those people who said hillary trump it's
all the same
it's all the same i'm gonna stay home or
i'm gonna write in whoever because they
said supreme court i don't care about
the supreme court when i was here saying
you realize what could happen if trump
wins and gets to pick supreme court
justices right and some of you said oh i
don't care about that that's not a big
deal
well there is some responsibility there
as well but most of it is the people who
voted for trump and trump and the
supreme court justices that he put there
we don't have to go crazy fighting about
it we just have to remember in case this
comes up again
if you didn't vote for hillary in 2016
this was the risk you assumed i'm not
saying you're a bad person but this was
the risk you assumed you thought it was
worth i don't know sending a message to
the dnc or
whatever and that's totally fine that's
your right but this was the risk you
assumed and uh now this is where we are
now the one thing here that could be a
silver lining
i've been saying
democrats are heading towards a
disastrous and potentially historic
defeat in the midterms in november
it's possible possible that this might
be what lights a fire under the left to
say wow now we see the repercussions
we've got to get out there and vote i'll
come back to that um let's go back a
little bit uh you know we we often talk
about how all supreme court nominees
play coy when asked about abortion and
they say well i might come before the
cord and i can't pre-judge and all these
different things just as a reminder
here's samuel alito
back at his confirmation hearing in 2006
kind of dancing around the question of
is abortion constitutionally protected
he said it was not in an earlier writing
before being nominated here's how he
danced around this question during his
confirmation hearings spectre then
brought up the often cited letter alito
wrote in 1985 in applying for a job in
the reagan white house stating the
constitution does not protect a right to
an abortion do you agree with that
statement today uh judge alito
well that was a correct statement of
what i thought in 1985 from my vantage
point in 1985 and that was
as a line attorney in the department of
justice in the reagan administration
today if the issue were to come before
me if i am fortunate enough to be
confirmed and the issue were to come
before me then i would have to i would
approach the question with an open mind
and i would i would listen to you
with an open mind notwithstanding
your 1985 statement
absolutely senator that was a statement
that i made at a prior period of time
when i was performing a different role
and as i said yesterday
when when someone becomes a judge you
really have to
put aside
the things that you did
as a lawyer
at prior points in your legal career and
think about legal issues the way a judge
thinks about legal issues
here are trump's three
supreme court nominees amy coney barrett
brett kavanaugh and neil gorsuch when
roe v wade an abortion precedent came up
during their confirmation hearings
is roe a super president how would you
define super precedent and i'm answering
a lot of questions about roe which i
think indicates that roe doesn't fall in
that category and scholars across the
spectrum say that doesn't mean that rose
should be overruled but descriptively it
does mean that it's okay not a case that
everyone has accepted and doesn't call
for its overruling as a judge it is an
important precedent of the supreme court
by it i mean roe v wade and planned
parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
which itself is an important factor
senator as the book explains
um the supreme court of the united
states is held and roe versus wade
that um
a fetus is not a person for purposes of
the 14th amendment
and the book explains that do you accept
that
that's the law of the land i accept the
law of the land center yes
so everybody just kind of playing it off
like i don't know you know there's
precedent it's the law i don't have any
big desire to overturn roe v wade but
now if nothing changes it will be gone
go back to what hillary clinton said
back in 2018 where she said quote
if brett kavanaugh becomes a supreme
court justice will he help gut or
overturn roe v wade which legalized
abortion in america yes
of course he will and she was right and
i am no fan of hillary uh but hillary
was right about many things it turns out
in retrospect this makes donald trump an
extraordinarily consequential president
trump as far as we know personally isn't
even pro-life trump was vocally
pro-choice until he was 68 years old and
then he ran as a republican and had to
come up with this explanation well i met
a kid i liked and the mom said at one
point she thought about aborting and so
then i was pro-life
nobody believes it if you're thinking
critically but it doesn't change that
trump may now be the most consequential
anti-abortion president in history at
this point in time a totally clueless
doofus
but he figured out a way to overturn roe
v wade something i don't think he even
cares about personally this lets each
state decide
do we restrict abortion do we ban
abortion and i've said
it isn't even really clear
what democrats could do to save the
midterms but this reality that states
now could
ban or restrict abortion in absolutely
authoritarian retrograde ways
maybe
it will help democrats not get crushed
in november we talked about what if
biden forgive some student loan debt
what about cannabis decriminalization i
don't know
this could be the thing it is possible
that this is exactly the
earth-shattering wake-up call that might
get people to go out and vote because
they realize this is dark ages stuff
we're leaving the country to retrograde
elements of society to run things and
this issue
could potentially reshape the midterms
and we'll talk about that more protests
are already surging police are setting
up barriers at the supreme court and
this could inspire all sorts of new
voters apathetic voters we just can't
say yet now what do people do in red
states
does everyone with common sense leave
the red states to go to the safe haven
of blue states i don't know do the
leftists flood the red states to make
them no longer red and it is really
quite the situation and you know for us
who live in blue states like new york
much will probably not change that's a
reality but for many people in other
parts of the country it will be a
disaster now what's next
what's next because some of the people
against abortion
are also against
interracial marriage
some of them are against divorce for
religious reasons or at least claim to
be
some of them are against gay adoption
some of them are against gay marriage
they want it to be legal to fire people
for their gender identity or sexual
orientation which by the way is still
legal in more than 20 states they want
to be able to
whatever and once they discover
that you can take away established
rights from people if you put the right
people on the court and do the right
things at the state level to get a case
in front of the supreme court why would
they stop here they're not going to that
is for damn sure so we are going
backwards and next i want to talk a
little bit about the reaction from
megaworld
to what we have learned uh overnight
okay so a leaked decision
politico obtaining the draft decision
the supreme court unless something
changes will be overturning roe v wade
and planned parenthood v casey
this will end federal abortion rights
it will push it to the states
many states will outright ban abortion i
told you yesterday oklahoma passing a
six-week abortion ban that's basically a
total ban most women don't know they're
pregnant until at least four to five
weeks a six-week abortion ban is just an
abortion ban so let's look at some
reactions i want to start with radical
trumpist congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
she started crying when she heard about
the decision
uh let's take a look at that video i
just want to make an announcement and
i'm i'm sorry i'm overwhelmed with
emotion
because
this is the best news of our lifetimes
the supreme court
has voted to overturn abortion rights
there's a draft opinion out now to
overturn roe versus wade this is a this
is a great victory uh it's a great
victory for god
and
and the unborn who have been innocently
slain
for for years my entire lifetime
and i'll just read this that says roe
was egregiously wrong from the start i
just want to okay
now i think marjorie taylor green is
completely out of her mind i think she's
nuts i think she's a horrible person but
we have to understand if you believe
abortion is murder right if you believe
that getting an abortion at seven weeks
is the same as a cold-blooded
assassination
it would be logical that you would react
like this and so i think she's nuts for
a whole bunch of different reasons and i
disagree with her view about abortion
completely but let's understand that if
you believed that this is kind of a a
logical reaction the god stuff is an
extra layer like without the god stuff i
guess you could believe the same thing
but uh so that's marjorie taylor green
laura ingram
says to women who wanted abortion just
moved to a different state this was
always this was a state issue and we
have to say ginsberg said it was shaky
and bad well and i i everyone has to
remember tonight like before everybody
freaks out
that this is now going to be determined
by you the people yeah like you can move
to you could live in new york and you
say look remember new york did that
standing ovation in albany you want to
know what sick is
it's not safe legal and rare anymore in
new york you get a standing ovation for
having abortion up until basically the
baby you know is out of the womb okay so
the reality of course is a lot of people
can't afford to move i mean listen the
same people who uh might be in a
situation where
they might want to seek an abortion and
they would have trouble paying for that
you think they can afford to move to a
different state in order to get it i
mean that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever now laura ingram is aware
that there are some on the left saying
maybe this will inspire
the left to get out and vote in november
and it could save the midterm for
democrats she doesn't agree though the
left is going in the stratosphere
tonight they're going nuts
they know their entire facade everything
they fought for this is the die the the
hill that they'll die on they're worried
that it's all going to come crumbling
down
and they think that that somehow this
leak is going to be a gift that could
rescue them for the midterms
well the thinking is misguided all right
so laura ingram says this won't save
democrats in november
uh republican trump is congresswoman
lauren beaubert put out a tweet in
response saying if your response to the
supreme court news
is to dust off your stupid pink hat from
2016
and go march to a support infanticide
re-evaluate your entire life
and then lastly fox host tomi lahren
says democrats are going to do their own
insurrection over this
uh talking about this leak do you think
that this was an intimidation tactic
absolutely an intimidation tactic and
also a distraction tactic here i think
that the only way the democrats have a
chance in november is if they rile
everybody up get people to the polls
with these emotional cultural issues of
course now what's funny about that is
it's republicans who use contrived
cultural issues to get people to the
polls like critical race theory
this issue of abortion is a real issue
it's about precedent it's about law it's
actually about a supreme court decision
when you have the supreme court actually
dealing with something it's not a
contrived issue the contrived issues are
on their side abortion is one that's
going to be very high emotion very
intense for the country this is their
effort to distract from everything
that's going wrong and play to the
heartstrings of those especially on the
left that this this issue is so
important too and i think we're going to
see the summer 2020 reignited with
protests and dare i say an insurrection
i know that's a dirty word but i think
we're going to see a lot more to come
this week i don't believe that we are
going to see an insurrection or a coup
attempt i think we will hopefully see
democrats say wow
look at what the it it took a few years
right it was i don't know trump hillary
i don't know
and then here's trump and he gets one
pick to the court and then he gets a
second pick and then he gets a third
pick and then mississippi says we're
gonna ban abortion and it's appealed
appealed appealed and then it goes to
the court and well we'll hear from the
court at some point and the court says
roe v wade is gone folks roe v wade is
gone that's it it took some years but
that's the way it ultimately worked let
me know if you believe
this changes the outlook for the
midterms find me on twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so let's talk about vladimir putin as
many of you remember we started talking
about the putin's health story a while
ago at the very start of the invasion of
ukraine by russia we got emails from a
couple of doctors who said
putin doesn't look good putin looks sick
we could be looking at any number of
different conditions and i said to all
of you this is speculation this is mere
idol speculation we then saw uh about
ten days ago
this video of vladimir putin where he is
sitting at a table he's gripping the
table almost for support he's like
pushed back against the chair he's
tapping his toe his left hand is shaky
and this renewed speculation that there
could be something very seriously wrong
with vladimir putin in the last 48 hours
a story came out in the british tabloid
the sun that putin is going to be having
cancer surgery and i didn't come to you
with the story because the sun is simply
not an appropriate source for our show
that story now has made it into the new
york post now i still come to you with
caution and i say the new york post is
basically the print version of fox news
it's still not a slam dunk that the
truth is exactly as is being reported
here but this is now becoming mainstream
enough
that since we've been talking about it
at this point for over a month i want to
talk about it with you the new york post
story says putin to undergo cancer
surgery and transfer power to the ex-fsb
chief
russian president vladimir putin is set
to undergo cancer surgery and
temporarily hand over power to a
hard-line former federal police chief
according to a new report putin will
transfer control of russia's government
to nikolai petruchev head of the russian
federal police's security council while
he is incapacitated during and after the
procedure according to a video from the
mysterious telegram channel general svr
the channel is purportedly run by a
former russian foreign intel service
lieutenant general
uh reported that putin has been told by
doctors he must undergo an operation the
anticipated surgery and recovery are
expected to incapacitate putin for a
short time according to the unconfirmed
report
um
putin is unlikely to agree to hand over
power for a longer period of time
i will say that this is the worst option
petruchev is an outright villain no
better than putin moreover he's more
cunning and i would say more insidious
than putin if he comes to power russians
problems will only multiply
um so
is this true
we don't really know we don't really
know that but what we do know is at this
point
speculation from doctors
video evidence
and
this kind of strange report all are
saying the exact same thing
and
whether this is responsible for putin's
actions in ukraine
is a different story altogether and the
reason that the speculation is related
to the invasion of ukraine would be well
if he believes that he's going to die
he may try to go out in a sort of final
blaze of trying to restore glory to the
former soviet union as he still idolizes
it or it may be a side effect of
medication that is making him
irrational there are also unconfirmed
reports that this is actually a
cognitive issue and and dementia it's
it's wild speculation at the micro level
but the macro story continues to be
more and more different types of stories
about putin's health so
all we can do is wait and see
and uh i don't even know that there's
more to say about it but the story
creeping creeping creeping more and more
into the mainstream
there is a new book coming out from
donald trump's former secretary of
defense mark esper in the book esper
says that donald trump wanted to have
black lives matter protesters shot
um
where do we start
axios reporting scoop esper says trump
wanted to shoot protesters this is from
mike allen uh mike allen a long history
of very uh important scoops uh the book
is called the sacred oath
former defense secretary mark esper
charges in a memoir out may 10 that
former president trump said when
demonstrators were filling the streets
around the white house after the death
of george floyd quote can't you just
shoot them just shoot them in the legs
or something
the book of sacred oath contains vivid
first-person revelations by a top
cabinet member bolstering outsider
accounts of extreme dysfunction in the
trump white house
esper was fired by trump after the 2020
election
that moment in the first week of june
2020 quote was surreal sitting in front
of the resolute desk inside the oval
office with this idea weighing heavily
in the air and the president red faced
and complaining loudly about protests in
dc
esper goes on to say the good news this
wasn't a difficult decision not shooting
protesters the bad news i had to figure
out a way to walk trump back without
creating the mess i was trying to avoid
this book was vetted at the highest
levels of the pentagon
some of the end of the four star
generals who vetted the book or reviewed
it
witnessed what esper witnessed
um
i mean listen there's a few different
things here first of all
shoot people for their speech
i thought they were for free speech for
all of the first amendment stuff they
claimed to be all about
trump saying well what about shooting
people exercising free speech rights
i want to go into a different direction
with this though
i find it
almost traitorous
that many of these former trump
administration officials wait sometimes
years to tell us about this stuff until
they can monetize it i would argue that
it was mark esper's duty to go public
with this when it was happening if a
president wants to shoot protesters for
protesting
then it is almost as outrageous to stay
quiet about it until you can make money
from it in a book i get why they do it
they all do it it's not unique to mark
esper but it is fundamentally not
loyalty to what is best for the country
it is a loyalty to what is best for his
wallet and i get it i know why they are
doing it but this is so extreme and so
outrageous that you could make the case
that it borders on treason
not to immediately blow the whistle
publicly on something like this now
let's be you know as charitable as
possible is it possible that mitch
mcconnell and the rnc told esper to sit
on this stuff let's see how far the
january 6th committee goes let's let's
wait before you it's possible but
there's no evidence of that and it
doesn't seem particularly likely i
disagree with conservatism but this idea
shoot protesters it's not conservatism
i'm not praising conservatism and i
disagree with conservatism but this is
not conservatism these ideas are
neo-reactionary authoritarianism and
it's republicans sort of resorting to
the absolute worst human traits
and uh some of them seem to lack the
intellectual capacity to turn these
things into reality trump thought about
shooting protesters he didn't do it his
secretary of defense wasn't willing to
do it as far as he claims i guess trump
just wasn't able to make it a reality a
less incompetent person at the helm
might actually be able to get some of
this stuff to become a reality and
that's why the idea of what about
desantis a less incompetent but just as
dangerous version of trump as a possible
republican nominee that's why it's so
dangerous and horrifying so
that's the latest from esper
i don't plan on buying the book i don't
read any of these types of books i've
got too much other stuff to read that i
find more interesting but
not a revelation that i would doubt
it is in line with everything we've seen
from donald trump but esper should have
gone public earlier with this we'll have
more on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show today
we're going to be speaking with
professor michael gambon who teaches
history at kutztown university of
pennsylvania specializing in modern
america also is author of the
forthcoming book modern conspiracies in
america separating fact from fiction
it's out in less than two weeks really
great to have you on i appreciate your
time oh thank you for having me i really
this is a great opportunity and i
appreciate it yeah so this this is such
an important topic right now in the
united states of america kind of in the
era of covet vaccines trumpism flat
earth the 2020 election we could kind of
go on and on and on we've talked
quite a bit about general techniques and
strategies
to talk to people
about beliefs that may not be based in
fact but i think we can all kind of feel
that there's a difference between the
belief that tax cuts for the rich are
good for the economy kind of in one
bucket and on the other side the belief
that i don't know
there uh is a secret plot to create the
covet pandemic in order to create an
opportunity to vaccinate people which
will then allow mind control and you
know on and on and on we can feel that
there's sort of some difference between
those two things can you first talk a
little bit about the difference between
beliefs that might just be wrong and
what we would characterize as a
conspiracy theory
yeah i think i mean when i started
teaching this class i really wanted it
to be a research class i mean how do you
figure out how to apply a basic template
for logic
so
what i always tell the students i said
you have a claim it has to be matched
with a proof it has to be
and then we can talk about degrees of
evidence so
we just finished up sandy hook and q
anon in my class and
one of the tells that you have is if you
have somebody making a claim simply
followed by more claims
uh with no proof in the you know
following in the wake of that then
that's a that's a huge flag
so and that's what you tend to always
want i tell me tune your ear to that you
know when you hear this kind of
hopscotching gish gallop
um you know moving along the surface
type of approach if it has no depth then
that's a problem so
we can talk about tax cuts and economics
fine
but if you're going to claim that a
microchip was in the uh you know coveted
vaccination show me the proof
and
the other way i look at it if you have
the big claims the giant global
conspiracies big claim requires big
proof it's the same
you know basically the same idea but
it's just a bigger threshold
is there a shortcut not to changing
people's minds we'll get later to the
changing of minds but to being able to
ascertain whether you're speaking to
someone who's open to revising their
views
i think so i think
you start you know
i think one of the things i said the
book is you apply the 80 20 rule i mean
you should be starting off by listening
more than talking
and i think that's a skill unfortunately
we're losing in civil discourse and
that's something i'm trying to teach in
class you know to sit back and listen
because teachers are the worst at this
we we're talkers we have captive
audiences so
first thing listen see where they're
coming from
um one of the key things you need to
know is the context i mean what are you
know where are they where do they live
um and so on you're basically trying to
build a
a profile of the person you're talking
to and just and simply you don't want to
go right to a quick conclusion and
dismiss them
so
that's what you're always doing in any
conversation
there's the other
kind of side to this
and i hesitate to ever say there's
another side to things when we're really
talking about kind of one-sided
circumstances but sometimes you will
hear the claim from some who assert
conspiratorial beliefs
that what you just accept everything
everybody tells you you always accept
the official story you accept what the
government says you i mean medicine has
been wrong science has been wrong
governments have lied etc what's the
best way to kind of handle that idea and
approach that
yeah i think i tell them and i have a
lot of criminal justice majors but i
think in general treat this like you
would if you're on a jury
so you have a burden of proof but one
thing you're never going to have is 100
certainty so you have to reach that
level to say is it 51 enough do i need
more
um so that's how you're measuring this
um and also we were just talking about
this uh this week um evidence evolves
um you have examples where you know in
in some of these you know conspiracies
you're gonna have revelations that might
take decades
or technology will change and you'll
have better ways to analyze something
so
patience is also a virtue for both of
those things and that's again you're
trying to teach americans patience
that's an ongoing enterprise
do you address the idea of sometimes one
might assert a certain belief not
because they actually believe it but
because it signals that they're part of
a team and i'll give an example of that
you know after the 2020 election there
was polling done about do you believe
trump won and the numbers among
republicans at the time were quite high
i think in the immediate aftermath it
was like 57 and that number has waned
over time but within that 57 percent
presumably there were some what we might
call true believers who literally
believe trump actually won but then
there are others for whom claiming it
signals support for trump or or
identifies them with the team for lack
of a better term
where does that figure in to the studies
and the work that you do
i think i've used uh a lot of polling
and a lot of uh analysis of polling
especially by uh an author named
barinsky um
you have you know influencers i mean
that's a new term but you've always had
people who lead opinions because they
they're trusted they have agency they're
public officials
um so people tend to rely on that and
they they can guide that or they can
abuse it i think joe mccarthy is a
classic example
um but one of the things that came up in
queueing on you know of all the reading
i did uh wired magazine had a great
story on you know how q and i is like an
alternate reality game
so what you have is you have a universe
basically it's world building so you've
got certainty
and rewards so
within that group um you have that
recognition
and i think what that lends people in
very uncertain times and this is very
historical i mean you could have said
this in 1919 or today it gives people an
anchor to hang on to in a very you know
difficult fearful uncertain time
so whether i'm a leader or a follower i
mean there are uses for these things
that
you know can be manipulated
yeah that you touched on something which
we've we've talked about before which is
if you take something like sandy hook as
an example or 9 11 maybe you're good
examples of this
sometimes it seems like one of the
primary motivating factors in getting
people to choose
one of these assertions rather than what
we might call the official empirically
based version of the story
is that the randomness with which bad
things happen in the world is
extraordinarily unsettling and so for
some folks it's almost more pacifying to
believe
it wasn't a random thing that could have
happened at any time it was planned it
was deliberate and and there's more
certainty in the world
is that an important psychologically
motivating factor for more than just a
few of these
absolutely um i use a book by rob
brotherton called suspicious minds and
he talks about the messy desk
test
where people instinctively want to
impose order on something that simple
but that applies to a lot of things in
life
so rather than be overwhelmed you can
you make this construct and
it works toward intellectual values but
also you know you could say uh instinct
um what you might seem as common sense
so one of the things we suspect is
always threats and we tend to associate
these threats with the other and it
could you know usually you know the
brand new immigrant i mean that's a
classic nativist go-to
in a lot of these conspiracies uh you
saw that in 16 with you know the three
million boats
um it's a constant drum beat even during
covid
um who's bringing covet well these other
people them
that's why when i first started the
class i looked at the protocols of the
elders of zion and it's amazing how that
keeps coming back in different forms but
it's basically the same thing that's
about as old as story as it gets but i
saw updates to this this year it's
amazing yeah let's talk a little bit
about anti-semitism i uh as a jewish
person myself you know i've been aware
of anti-semitism for as long as i can
remember being aware of of anything
and
a lot of the modern conspiracy theories
sometimes much more subtly than others
go back to or have their roots in an
anti-semitic idea you know the idea of
the other bringing disease that's a
classic anti-semitic idea from you know
800 900 years ago at least uh globalist
now often used as a sort of uh
catch-all for
wealthy jewish men right when we talk
about they talk about soros they talk
about klaus schwab is a big big one here
um can you talk a little bit about
where the origins of of so many of these
things stemmed from anti-semitism and
whether even some of the conspiracy
theorists realize that
i i don't think they do although it's
been constantly pointed out
so for q anon you have you know the
endless stories about blood drinking and
child trafficking
and i i the first thing i automatically
think of is the blood libel which goes
back for centuries
so i think at the root of a lot of these
conspiracies and i think richard
hofstadter pointed this out really well
you've got a moral judgment that you're
making you're posing a moral threat not
just a political or social or an
economic one so you've got this group of
identified outcasts that you're posing
as a threat to the social order
and you can go very viscerally you know
in the case of q and on with the
children
so that's a very consistent theme uh
threats to children whether it's the
middle ages or right now
and we can always associate that with
this you know labeled outcast group
it keeps reoccurring because it works um
it's it's odd to see
anyone's going to argue against
protecting children i mean it's very
altruistic but it can be very easily
distorted and it is i saw this during
the supreme court nomination
um what do you make of flat earth
surging
at a time when we have the most advanced
technology we've ever had
and the most sort of empirical means of
ascertaining the real shape of a planet
well we do we do chemtrails in class so
it's kind of in the same ballpark
one of the common themes i see in all
these conspiracies is there are always
complexities
um i don't know too many people who know
structural engineering enough to talk
about 911 or
epidemiology since 2020 so
i think in all these things what you
have with like flat earth is a way to
simplify
and take back an idea that experts
control
and in the meantime what you're doing is
making enormous numbers of mistakes
but you have certainty and you don't
care about the complexity uh you're just
basically bypassing it i love talking
about chemtrails and flat earth because
my science majors lose their minds when
they look at some of the basic mistakes
but that goes back to you know
you know things you can look up and
assert
back to the education system and you
know competing with the ability to
oversimplify that's that's that's kind
of the tug of war you have going on with
that
so now let's talk about changing minds
uh we've had many different
conversations with experts about how do
you change minds you know the
low-hanging fruit is beating people over
the head with facts is rarely effective
uh showing empathy listening a lot as
you point out is effective but still
we've not really found any significant
shortcut i mean oftentimes you're
talking about building a relationship
with someone not even over a period of
hours but often over days weeks months
or whatever the case may be
where
what is your sense of the most effective
techniques to change minds
you know it's well i'm an educator
obviously i've been doing this for a
long time and
one of the devices i had set up was
having
you know
a group of students assertive conspiracy
and a group of students debunked a
conspiracy and
we're training them in basic logic
facts but also in civil discourse
so in combination that's where i have
some hope because that's the thing you
don't have really online you have
you know threads where the insults break
out in seconds and
it
that's not the way that should work i
mean the face-to-face version of this is
the better way because
you know outside the internet that's the
way people used to debate and you can
look somebody in the eye
i think it's a very hard thing to do i
think one of the things that struck me
about the recent past
shows with a sense of humor who don't
take themselves too seriously
um well are very effective that's what
jon stewart proved years ago
john oliver does that still i mean
you can you can say this stuff with a
smile on your face and not the dark
implications of disagreement so part of
its method part of its structure
um i'm going to keep working away at it
as long as i'm teaching which is going
to be for more years than now so we'll
see
when it comes to like assessing the
i i i'm going to use the word danger but
maybe it's not actually the right word
but when it comes to assessing the
danger of widespread belief of a
particular conspiracy theory i think
many of us can understand how at least
in a direct sense there are some
conspiracy theories like for example the
comet ping pong thing that led to an
actual shooting whereas for many of us
we say flat earth it's comparatively
more benign some experts we've
interviewed say
that's true and yet
it's rare that someone believes only one
of these things and flat earth links to
something else and it links to
anti-semitism and all these different
things so okay we're let's try to put
together sort of a theory of this we can
understand the differences between the
immediate impacts of some of these
conspiracy theories but how do we
evaluate them on some kind of spectrum
i think one of the things i noticed with
q and on was that it was early on
dismissed as lone actors on the fringe
and i think what
obviously january 6 proved a lot of that
wrong
the same systems where these beliefs can
overlap and combine
you know with whatever you know media
platform you have they're also the same
places that these threats can organize
themselves
and that's a huge concern
because you can't really shut down
social media it's like playing
electronic whack-a-mole um you can ban
somebody from a platform they'll just
move to another one
so i i'm really concerned after night
i'm sorry after january 6th when it
comes to coordinating acting
people will move on their convictions
and like you mentioned in the polling
these aren't small numbers of people
even if you take the tiniest percentage
you still have a lot of people willing
to act on what they're doing and that
really concerns me because there's you
know the treatment of this is almost
like a crusade
um
so in my own classroom or you know i'm
gonna i actually have an election worker
i'll be at the polls in two weeks
i'm constantly worried about somebody
showing up you know to try to make sure
that the election's not stolen
i've been asked that question dozens of
times in two years
so i do have concerns
let's talk a little bit about social
media um
in the book technopoly neil postman
wrote that there's a sort of uh
naivete in thinking that with any
platform or technology
you can eliminate any of the bad uses of
it and only be left with the sort of
good and i'm oversimplifying but the
idea that a platform a technology comes
with good and bad and the question is
finding a balance of sort of regulation
and education
that will maximize the good and minimize
the bad we can think about lots of great
things about social media and also it
has made the spread of conspiracy
theories and false beliefs rampant like
wildfire
what should be a regulatory framework
for some of these platforms well that's
a big that's a big question um
so best example i have online is a
website called metabunk which has
moderated conversations
um they do have standards and it it
works um
but how far that could be extended and
spread you know throughout the entire
internet you know that that's that's the
problem um
and i think you pointed out i mean where
these things might appear in places you
would have never suspected
uh the natural parenting community in
cuban i mean no one saw that
although you could see the elements
after the fact so
it's a very hard thing to talk about the
more you crank down on free speech the
more that you're gonna have the reaction
and
i think it becomes self-defeating after
a point um
i'm back to trying to you know the
education part before they log on i mean
that's that's what i'm looking at that
that's i mean for me the greatest
immunizer to people falling for this
stuff is you start teaching critical
thinking and media literacy
probably at age 11 or something like
that right
well and judging by the this course has
changed since i started you know back in
2016. i had 25 students right now i have
145. wow so i this thing get it it fills
in within a couple days every time i run
it and i run multiple sections now so
it might be like a factory for reason
and rational thinking i hope right
that's the dream and the book is
forthcoming in uh less than two weeks
it's modern conspiracies in america
separating
fact from fiction i've pre-ordered it on
amazon already uh i encourage the
audience to do the same we've been
speaking with the book's author
professor michael gambon really
appreciate your time today and this was
a treat i got to tell you thank you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so abortion is really the story of the
day we learned late last night thanks to
a political report that the supreme
court plans to overturn both roe v wade
and planned parenthood v casey and this
will essentially do away with any kind
of federal fundamental right to an
abortion in most cases that women have
marjorie taylor green the radical
repugnant trumpist congresswoman
made a really wild statement just a few
days ago about abortion i just haven't
had time to get to it today but i want
to look at it this was a comment made
before we learned of the forthcoming
supreme court decision
in which marjorie taylor green
raises some really wacky religious stuff
where she says women get abortions
because satan comes up to them and
whispers in their ear
if you get the abortion
the guy who impregnated you will marry
you which of course
ignores the reality that if you're
pregnant because you've been raped
i don't know that you want the rapist to
marry you it's a vile vile statement but
it shows us the level of religious
delusion that exists for many of these
people now i will say again earlier when
we played the clip of marjorie taylor
green crying because she was so happy by
the supreme court decision that we
learned about
i said i think she's nuts but if you
believe abortion is murder it's logical
you would be very happy if abortion is
ending i understand that
this is just unhinged religious nuttery
that is you know it's about angels and
demons and ghosts and this type of stuff
take a listen
it's whispered softly and gently into
your ears and into your soul
and he tells you it's okay
and he says it's just
this one thing
you're just gonna get it done get it
over with and then he tells you a
promise
he promises you
all these dreams that that you have in
your heart
and that's how satan sells a sin and
that's how he sells abortion he tells a
woman
that
all you have to do is you're just going
to go to this clinic
just going to get it over with you know
and then you're going to that guy he's
going to stay with you that that
boyfriend or the guy whoever he is he's
going to marry you sweep you off your
feet
so
first of all this is so specific that
it's extra strange i'm not saying she's
recounting a personal experience but it
is so specific that it is very weird
she seems to have no idea or concern
with the reality that there are people
in all sorts of situations who make
really tough decisions about what is
best for them
and sometimes it has to do with being a
victim of sexual assault rape sometimes
it has to do with a fetus with an
abnormality that would prevent ever
having anything close to a normal and
fulfilling life and would be suffering
uh sometimes it's
other things the point is
it ignores i mean this is this is like
psych ward stuff
and uh it ignores the reality of the
circumstances in which sometimes women
and families and and couples
choose to make really difficult
decisions but it's also paranormal and
bizarre
and one of the unfortunate things is you
know earlier i said if you believe
abortion is murder it's logical you
would be happy for it to stop okay but i
understand that framework
on the other hand
if
you are making decisions or having
opinions about what civil law should be
based on your evidence-free belief about
angel angels demons demons ghosts and
satan
it's hard to imagine you could ever be a
productive and reasonable member of uh
of a legislative body to put it to put
it quite frankly and uh it's
extraordinarily dangerous and it's
extraordinarily disturbing
let's talk about free speech um truth
social which donald trump misstated as
truth social at a rally a week ago
it is the
trump social media platform which
the people on the right who like the
platform promote as a free speech
platform now this this should already
set off an alarm in our heads
because
most platforms describe themselves by
what they are not by the vague term free
speech platform so like youtube
is a video platform i don't know exactly
what their current tag line is but it's
the biggest videos video sharing site in
the world
to call it a free speech platform would
be kind of weird it's a video platform
and they have terms of service that
people have to abide by okay
um facebook is the biggest
social
whatever platform
free speech platform to me would signal
it's almost like a penis size contest
where it's something you say to get
attention
for that and when we talk about truth
social and we actually look at their
terms of service
it turns out they have the exact same
guidelines as any other platform and so
when i hear free speech platform i think
it's a platform for speech that they
like
check this out here are all of the
different reasons that you can report a
post on truth social
based on their terms of service and
terms and conditions if you see illegal
activity
content that depicts illegal or criminal
acts or threats of violence okay that's
standard every platform has that
intellectual property infringement
impersonating another account or
business infringing on intellectual
property rights well
that's unadjudicated so someone can just
assert that there's some kind of
infringement and you don't even go
through due process to prove it and the
content can be removed wow that that
doesn't sound like the free speech
platform they claim it to be but it does
sound like basically every other
platform on the internet
sensitive content if there is violence
gore or nudity the content can be pulled
oh so like every other platform if
there's underage content sexually
explicit content involving underage
children oh that's just like on youtube
just like on facebook just like on
twitter
prostitution any solicitation or
advertising for illegal sexual activity
or sex for hire
any privacy violation if you violate or
post content that violates a person's
privacy rights
just like every other platform
illegal sales if you sell or promote
illegal drugs counterfeit services and
goods or illegal products and services
well even counterfeit isn't it the
uh buyer beware
freedom for whoever wants to engage in
commerce to decide i want to buy this
and maybe it's a fake product or not but
that that that's not exactly free speech
and lastly doxxing sharing or
threatening to share private information
of individuals without their consent so
basically
it's a lot of cancer culture now i'm
joking in reality it's the exact same
stuff we see on every platform
interestingly truth social has welcomed
and become a sort of de facto
safe haven for a lot of the people who
supported the riots on january 6 2021
supported the coup support of the
insurrection
by their own terms of service
all of that information
uh and depictions of what was done
would have to be removed by truth social
and um we have to understand that a free
speech platform
is a red alert alarm that they mean
speech we like and are choosing to
coddle now after the disastrous launch
of the platform it seems as though now
they've explained to trump sir you've
got to be a little more involved here
and trump finally made his first post on
truth social months after it launched
um
and uh the the message is i'm back
hashtag
kobffe
and it features a picture of trump
using his phone in front of mar-a-lago
in palm beach florida
uh and it seems to have been potentially
removed from
twitter there was a picture of the post
on twitter
so it's not even really clear trump
cares about this thing i think he knows
there's not very many people on it it's
probably just another gif grift or cash
grab so truth social not that much free
speech
trump's not even really on the platform
and it's yet another way to take
advantage of their followers who seem
more than thrilled about opportunities
to be taken advantage of
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
um i mentioned this a little bit earlier
in our segment about the supreme court
apparently imminently overturning roe v
wade
here's a caller who's thinking along
some similar lines that i am take a
listen to this
hi david this is keisha from florida um
the
supreme court just
put out a notice to overturn road versus
weight yeah do you think um same sex
marriages and
interracial marriages is next
um
i would love to hear your commentary
thank you yeah so like i said earlier
i don't know
whether there will develop a concerted
effort to end interracial marriage at
the state level
or to end
gay marriage or what i i can't say for
sure that that's where energy is going
to be focused
but some of the people who are against
abortion are also against those things
and there's nothing that will more
invigorate these reactionary movements
than getting what they see as a win and
this was a win that took a while like i
said earlier it took trump had to win in
2016
get his first opportunity to put a
supreme court justice on the court the
second one the third one then you needed
to see these state-level abortion bans
start to uh be put together and then to
be fought and then to be appealed to the
court and then the court had to take one
of those cases and okay so it's a
process but it is a win for them there's
no question about it and so in general
when you get an inch you then try to
take a mile and i absolutely think there
will be some movement to go further and
go beyond just stopping abortion i don't
know if it'll be interracial marriage
gay marriage rules about employment or
whatever else the case may be but they
aren't going to stop here that's for
sure we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today campaign season is on we have
primaries today in ohio and in some
other places and there are many more
primaries this month we're going to talk
about the midterms are now happening on
the bonus show we will talk about
another supreme court
decision
in which the supreme court has found
that first amendment rights were
violated when a group wanted to put a
christian flag outside of city hall
we'll talk about that and what
texas republican governor greg abbott
has been doing at the border between
texas and mexico has turned out to be an
extraordinary economic opportunity for
the state of new mexico we will talk
about what's going on there as well all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com
uh you will get instant access to the
bonus show you'll get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
don't wait
all day for clips to be released of the
show you'll get the entire show
commercial free hours earlier than
everybody else when you become a member
at joinpacman.com
i'll see you on the bonus show or
otherwise tomorrow and reminder
wednesday night tomorrow wednesday night
may 4th i will be live with the next
pennsylvania
senate republican debate that's the one
with mehmet oz the guy who suggests
quack cures on tv and other republicans
running for the republican nomination in
that race tomorrow night we'll be live
with that as well see everybody soon on
the bonus show tomorrow tomorrow
you